SALLY:  Ich habe in den 9 Jahren YouTube-Geschichte…
"Oh Gott! Neiiiin!"
Da ist mir noch nicht so viel Schlimmes passiert…
"Sallys Welt hat versagt"
[Thriller-Musik] … wie bei dieser einen Torte.
[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es mal wieder nach langer, langer Zeit ein Schmecksperiment.
Ich habe nämlich auf Pinterest einen Kuchen entdeckt,
der sich Jelly Fruit Cake nennt.
Es gibt kontroverse Meinungen darüber in unserem Team.
Manche sagen: "Boah, krass, finde ich mega."
Andere sagen: "Oh, voll eklig."
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir probieren es einfach.
Wir machen jetzt ein Jelly Fruit Cake und Team Sally darf später probieren.
Die Basis ist ein lockerer Biscuit-Teig.
Dann kommt eine fruchtige Schicht mit einer lockeren Creme rein.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich eine Quark-Sahne-Creme zubereiten
Drumherum werden Früchte dekoriert und diese aufgegossen.
Es sieht schon fancy aus, muss ich sagen.
Ich gucke jetzt, wie ich das Ganze so ein bisschen noch upgraden kann,
was den Geschmack betrifft, denn die Kuchen, die ich gesehen habe,
sehen sehr simpel aus - von den Zutaten her.
Ich pack da jetzt einfach Geschmack mit rein.
Ich denke, es wird schon recht gut.
Ich habe hier schon einmal 2 Backringe auf 18 cm Durchmesser gestellt.
Ihr könnt den Kuchen auch größer machen,
aber da müsst ihr natürlich auch bedenken, ihr müsst viel mehr dekorieren.
Ich mache ihn eher schmal und hoch.
Also es verteilt sich so ein bisschen.
und ich mache einfach meinen Basis-Biscuit-Teig.
Dafür nehme ich 4 Eier, eine Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt
100 g Zucker, 100 g Mehl und ich gebe noch Limettenabrieb dazu.
Ihr könnt jetzt zuerst die Eier mit dem Salz, Vanilleextrakt und Zucker
etwa 10-15 Min. cremig verrühren.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt perfekt aus, schön luftig geschlagen.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Limettenschale dazu reiben.
Drauf achten, immer nur den grünen Teil und natürlich eine Limette verwenden,
bei der man die Schale mit verzehren kann.
Dann siebe ich noch das Mehl dazu, hebe es kurz unter
und dann ist der Biskuit fertig.
[Musik]
Den Teig ist schön auf die zwei Backformen aufteilen.
So verkürzt sich auch gut die Backzeit.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch alles in einem Backring backen,
aber wie gesagt, dann dauert es beim Backen ein bisschen länger.
[Musik]
Und direkt im vorgeheizten Ofen backen.
[Uhr]
[Musik]
Der Biskuit ist gebacken und abgekühlt.
Aber auch noch vor dem Abkühlen könnt ihr euch im Prinzip schon
um die Eiswürfel kümmern. Die Torte soll ja im Prinzip eine
Mojito-Torte werden und ich habe mir überlegt, ich mache jetzt Jellys
und fülle sie Eiswürfelbehälter und das wird dann schon!
Also ich nehme jetzt dafür 500 g Wasser.
Ihr könnt aber auch z.B. einen klaren Apfelsaft nehmen.
Ich möchte es jetzt aber relativ durchsichtig halten.
1 Päckchen Agar Agar, ein bisschen Minze habe ich aus dem Garten
und Zucker brauche ich auch. Den hab ich noch hier.
Das probieren wir jetzt gleich. Das wird!
Was ihr jetzt nur machen müsst und solltet,
vor allem, wenn ihr mit Agar Agar arbeitet:
Die Masse muss natürlich schön aufkochen,
damit das Agar Agar seine Wirkung entfalten kann.
Es ist ein pflanzliches Schmiermittel statt Gelatine.
Finde ich ganz gut, weil da muss ich sagen,
verzichte ich gerne auf tierische Produkte.
Immer wenn es geht natürlich.
Das kommt hier rein.
Und wie gesagt, für den Geschmack die Minze.
Falls ihr aber Minzgeschmack nicht mögt,
könnt ihr z.B. auch ein bisschen Aromen dazu geben,
wie zum Beispiel Himbeeraroma oder auch einfach Vanille
- egal, wonach es schmecken soll.
Ich glaube, ich würde jetzt einfach einmal
- wir sind ja beim Schmecksperiment, Schmecksperiment!
Ich gebe jetzt einfach mal 40 g Zucker dazu. Ich mag es nicht so süß.
Dann werden es wie vegane Gummibärchen,
nur nicht in Bärchenform.
Das koche ich jetzt 2 Min. lang auf.
[Musik]
So, das durfte jetzt hier 2 Min. kochen.
Jetzt kann ich die Minzblätter absieben
und das Ganze dann in Eiswürfelbehälter füllen.
[Gitarre - live]
PATRICK: ♪ Ice, ice Baby. ♪
♪ Ice, ice Baby. ♪
[Sally lacht; Jubel]
SALLY: Perfekt!
Der Patrick ist da, unser Nachbar, unser Plotter und Folierer.
So nennt man es, so heißt es, oder? [Patrick bejaht]
Aber auch ein großer großer Musikkünstler.
PATRICK: Ich bin nicht so groß, aber…
SALLY: Doch, für mich schon!
Der Patrick macht demnächst ein richtig cooles Event.
Wie heißt es?
PATRICK: Es ist ein Picknick-Konzert als 360°-Session.
Die Band steht in der Mitte.
Das Publikum sitzt auf Picknickdecken außen rum.
SALLY: Und das findet demnächst hier in Waghäusel statt, oder? [Patrick bejaht]
Am?
PATRICK: Am 25.07.2021. Das ist ein Sonntag.
Hat jeder Zeit, hoffentlich.
SALLY: Richtig cool. Wir haben gesagt - wir sind ja auch aus Waghäusel -
da sind wir natürlich mit dabei und kommen auch aufs Konzert.
Also Tickets an sich kann man so nicht kaufen,
aber man kauft praktisch Picknickdecken, denn
denn man muss ja alles coronakonform mit begrenzter Zuschaueranzahl
Dann gibt's Picknickdecken, Einzeldecken, Doppeldecken - irgendwie so.
Da könnt ihr euch aber gerne auch die Infos auf der Webseite anschauen.
Vielleicht haben wir ja bis dahin eine Website.  [Beide lachen]
PATRICK: www.360grad-session.de. Die gibt's.
SALLY: Sehr gut und da stehen alle Infos.
Wo es bis dahin die Decken gibt, steht dann auch da.
denn es ist alles grad noch in der Planung und Organisation.
Man muss natürlich schauen, alle Richtlinien usw.,
aber es wird cool, oder? Wie lange geht das dann ungefähr?
PATRICK: Es geht zweimal ca. 50 Min. plus Zugabe, wenn ihr eine wollt.
SALLY: Schön, wird bestimmt ein tolles Event.
Vor allem freue ich mich drauf,
weil es einfach endlich mal wieder stattfindet,
draußen im Freien unter dem Himmel
- einfach mit Menschen und Unterhaltung. [Patrick stimmt zu]. Ach schön!
PATRICK: Wir sehen uns danach.
SALLY: Ja, ich backe jetzt hier.
Es wird ein Schmecksperiment. Ich mache sowas wie eine Mojito-Torte.
Ich habe da so einen Trend gesehen und ich probier's einfach aus.
Wenn es klappt, schreib ich dir. Du kannst probieren.
PATRICK: Bin gespannt. Ich komme!
SALLY: Okay. Ich beeile mich.
Dann schaffe ich es vielleicht noch vor deinem Feierabend.
PATRICK: Perfekt.
SALLY: Ja? Danke dir!
PATRICK: Bis später.
SALLY: Bis später.
[Musik]
Die Masse lasse ich jetzt hier einfach einmal abkühlen.
Ich decke jetzt auch gar nicht ab,
dass es noch ein bisschen ausdampfen kann
und wenn es dann abgekühlt ist, kommt es nochmal in den Kühlschrank,
damit es richtig schön fest wird.
Ich werde jetzt einfach schon einmal Erdbeeren vorbereiten.
Erdbeeren und Pfirsich nehme ich jetzt für die Füllung
und mache auch gleich eine Creme.
Die Erdbeeren werde ich jetzt einfach entstielen und fein schneiden.
PATRICK: Ja, das machen wir jetzt.
[Musik]
SALLY: Jetzt bereite ich die Creme zu.
Wie gesagt, mache ich eine Quark-Sahnecreme.
Dafür nehme ich 500 g Quark, 80 g Puderzucker, Vanilleextrakt,
den Saft der Limette - die habe ich vorhin abgerieben -,
400 ml Sahne und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Es ist praktisch eine ganz normale Quark-Sahnecreme
oder Käse-Sahnecreme, wie man sie auch gerne nennt.
Hier jetzt einfach den Quark in die Rührschüssel geben,
mit Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt abschmecken.
Dann den Limettensaft dazugeben und kurz verrühren.
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit schon,
wieviel Jelly-Masse ich brauche.
Aber ich glaub ich mach es einfach so:
Ich habe praktisch meine runde Torte, 18 cm. [Spannende Musik]
Die Höhe. Dann rechne ich da das Volumen aus.
Dann lege ich später einen größeren Tortenring rum, wahrscheinlich 22
und dann rechne ich da das Volumen aus.
Und dann ziehe ich den 18er vom 22er ab.
Und dann habe ich das Innenvolumen minus ein bisschen die Früchte.
Und dann hab ich die Jelly-Masse.
Wird schon klappen, oder Josh?
Dann jetzt hier weiter die Sahne dazu gießen
und mit San-apart steif schlagen
und einfach immer drauf achten, dass diese Zutaten hier schön kalt sind.
[Musik]
Die Sahne stelle ich kurz zur Seite
und kann jetzt hier schon die Biskuitböden
- herausgelöst hab ich sie ja schon -
jetzt einmal halbieren.
Einfach mit einer Tortensäge oder mit einem Messer.
[Musik]
Dann kann jetzt die Torte gefüllt werden.
Das mache ich immer gern auf einer Tortendrehplatte.
Da kann ich schön gleichmäßig arbeiten.
Also zuerst ein bisschen Creme,
dann schön verstreichen.
Wer möchte, kann jetzt die Tortenböden auch noch tränken.
Wenn ihr jetzt wirklich so eine Cocktail-Torte daraus machen wollt,
wie so eine Mojito-Torte - wird Mojito mit Rum oder was kommt da rein?
JUTTA: Nein, das ist kein Rum. Das ist Pitu.
JOSH: Pitu ist Zuckerrohrschnaps.
SALLY: Dann können wir das nehmen, was eben in den Cocktail reinkommt.
Das könnt ihr dann wirklich schön auf die Biskuitböden drauf geben
und einfach ein bisschen einziehen lassen.
Dann habt ihr wirklich den Cocktailgeschmack auch mit dabei.
Ich mache das hier aber ohne.
[Musik]
Dann kommen da jetzt die Früchte rein.
Also Erdbeeren, Pfirsiche, alles was ihr gern habt, in schönen Scheiben.
[Musik]
Einfach nur eine Schicht Creme obendrauf, schön glatt streichen,
den nächsten Boden und so dann einfach die komplette Torte füllen.
[Musik]
Dann den Deckel drauf
und mit der Restcreme könnt ihr schon einmal schön den Rand einstreichen,
damit die Torte schön glatt wird.
Meiner Torte wird es jetzt schon ein bisschen zu warm.
Die kommt jetzt gleich in den Kühlschrank
Wenn sie dann schön durchgezogen und fest ist,
kann ich mich um die Geleemasse kümmern
bzw. ich streiche sie dann vorher noch einmal richtig schön glatt
und dann geht's ans Gelee.
Aber ihr seht schon, die wackelt noch so ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, ich friere sie sogar kurz ein,
aber wenn ihr Zeit habt, könnt ihr sie auch einfach für 2h kühl stellen.
[Musik]
Die Torte kommt jetzt schnell, ganz, ganz, ganz schnell in die Kühlung.
Sonst wird das kein Schmecks-, sondern ein Schrecksperiment.
Seht ihr das? Wie warm und wackelig sie ist? Oh, oh!
Ich habe hier einmal einen Eiswürfel.
Jutta, komm! Wir probieren jetzt einmal alle - jeder so ein Viertel.
[Musik]
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Ich kann es auch nicht fassen, Jutta. Ich fass' es nicht.
SALLY: Ja, die Konsistenz ist schon anders.
Gummibärchen sind so gummimäßiger,
wobei hier die Konsistenz cooler finde, weil es nicht klebt.
SARAH: Ich mag den Minzegeschmack.
SALLY: Wie so ein Minzbonbon.
JOSH: Ich finde es eklig.
SARAH: Also ich finde die Konsistenz auch nicht so…
JUTTA: Von der Optik her…
SALLY: Wisst ihr was? Ich friere zwei Dinger, dass sie kälter werden.
JOSH: Ich finde es ein bisschen bitter.
SALLY: Das ist die Minze.
SARAH: Ich finde es zu bröckelig. Es bröckelt so.
SALLY: Wir gucken gleich.
Esst Erdbeeren. Hier, esst Erdbeeren.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Sollte ich bei diesem Wetter in Waghäusel eine Torte backen?
SMARTPHONE:
Bei dieser Temperatur sollte der Ofen nicht angemacht werden.
Geh lieber an den See, Sally.
SALLY: Ok.
[Musik]
Neuer Tag, neues Glück. [Hahnenschrei]
Bei 38 Grad sollte man definitiv keine Sahnetorten backen,
musste ich auch lernen, aber ist okay.
Jetzt backe ich die Torte einfach neu.
Ich hab den Biscuit gemach, die Creme, die Erdbeeren sind geschnitten.
Ich verzichte heute auch auf Pfirsich.
Ich fand jetzt doch Erdbeeren schöner.
Jetzt wird die Torte schön neu gestapelt und kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Die muss schon schon perfekt sein.
Ich habe auch gesehen:
Für den perfekten Anschnitt machen es ganz viele sogar so,
dass sie sich extra hier die Achtel sozusagen markieren
und dass man dann praktisch perfekt durch die Erdbeeren durchschneidet.
Also so extrem mache ich es jetzt nicht,
aber ich mach trotzdem einen schönen Anschnitt.
Wichtig ist beim Arbeiten einfach immer,
dass ihr diese Ebenen schön glatt macht.
Also immer eine schöne glatte Sahnebene,
dann Erdbeeren drauf und dann wieder glatt.
Das Gute ist, die Eiswürfel haben es überlebt.
Die können wir noch weiter benutzen.
[Musik]
Zum Stabilisieren nehme ich jetzt aber am besten,
dass das Ganze auch eine schöne Form bekommt,
eine Tortenrandfolie und einen Tortenring.
Dann kann ich sicher gehen, dass dieses Mal diese Torte wundervoll wird.
Diesmal stabilisiere ich es mit der Tortenrandfolie und dem Tortenring,
damit die Torte schön rund wird.
Irgendwie habe ich sie zu locker!
[Singend] In dieser Torte ist ein Wurm drin.
So kommen sie jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Heute ist auch ein kühlerer Tag, ein besserer Tag, um Torten zu backen.
So, und wenn die kalt ist,
streiche ich sie mit der Creme noch schön glatt.
Ich habe leider nicht mehr so viel Creme.
Ich muss noch ein bisschen was machen,
aber das hatte ich ja letzte Woche schon.
Aber ich dachte, heute reicht es.
Ich habe gemerkt, nein, reicht doch nicht und
dann geht es gleich weiter.
[Musik]
Gut! Sieht doch schon besser aus.
Die Temperatur spielt auf jeden Fall eine große Rolle beim Tortenbacken.
Gut, die Torte stelle ich jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Bzw. sogar Gefrierschrank, wenn ihr Platz habt.
In der Zeit kann ich mich jetzt um die Früchte kümmern,
die praktisch an den Rand der Torte kommen.
Ich werde jetzt Limetten, Erdbeeren
und ein bisschen Minze aus dem Garten nehmen.
Das Ganze soll, wie gesagt, an einen Mojito, Hugo o.Ä. erinnern.
So eine Art Getränk.
Deswegen stelle ich die kurz kühlend
und die Früchte, die Erdbeeren werde ich schön halbieren.
und die Limetten wahrscheinlich in Scheiben schneiden.
Für den Rand der Torte nämlich jetzt richtig schöne Erdbeeren.
Ich wollte sie erst halbieren, aber die sind doch recht groß.
Ich schneide sie Scheiben, so hab ich auch schön die Schnittfläche.
Ich habe jetzt nochmal den Rapido.
Damit bekomme ich nämlich exakt 5 mm dicke Erdbeerscheiben.
Weil es aber mit Limetten jetzt nicht geht,
nehme ich hier noch meine Hölzer, die ich oft zum Ausrollen nehme.
Und zwar werde ich jetzt hier die Limette dazwischen legen und
bekomme die dann auch in gleichmäßige Scheiben geschnitten.
[Musik]
Ich hätte schon vor dem Befüllen der Torte eine Frischhaltefolie
drunter legen sollen, weil später diese Jelly-Masse drumherum kommt,
aber jetzt muss ich ganz kurz die Upside-down-Technik machen.
Also wenn ihr es nachmacht, unter den ersten Boden Frischhaltefolie
und dann die Torte befüllen.
Ich muss das jetzt kurz so machen. Es wird klappen.
So, schwups!
Und wieder zurück.
Jetzt kommt der etwas aufwendige Part.
Jetzt werden praktisch die Erdbeeren- und Limettenscheiben
und die Minze schön an den Rand dekoriert.
Das sollte jetzt wirklich sehr sauber aussehen,
damit später der Effekt dann auch da ist.
[Musik]
Noch ein Tipp fürs Gelingen:
Am besten die Limetten so ein bisschen ausdrücken,
zwischen ein bisschen Küchenrolle oder auf einem sauberen Geschirrtuch,
damit sie einfach nicht so nass sind und besser halten
und eben nicht durchnässen.
Wenn es euch gefällt…
Ich finde es recht cool. Oh, die Münze fehlt.
Dann auf jeden Fall die Torte wieder einfrieren
und in der Zwischenzeit Jelly-Masse kochen.
Jetzt kommt meine Rechenformel, wieviel ich benötigen werde.
[Musik]
Also die Torte hat jetzt einen Durchmesser von 18 cm.
Also werde ich jetzt im Prinzip die Jelly-Masse herstellen,
so wie bei den Eiswürfeln, nur eben mit 1,5 l Wasser und ohne Minze,
denn da möchte ich, dass es wirklich ganz glasklar bleibt.
2 Min. aufkochen und ein bisschen abkühlen lassen, bis es lauwarm wird.
[Musik]
Also Wasser, Zucker und Agar Agar aufkochen.
Ich muss ja persönlich sagen:
Ich finde so eine Jelly-Masse ziemlich eklig. [Doing]
Sie ist eigentlich wie Wackelpudding.
Ich gebe jetzt einmal noch Zitronenöl dazu - Zitronenbackaroma,
dass es so ein bisschen Geschmack hat,
weil alles andere, was ich jetzt dazugeben würde,
wäre farbig und das möchten wir nicht - soll ja durchsichtig sein.
Also Backaroma - Schmecksperiment. Wir werden sehen.
[Musik]
Nach der Kochzeit fülle ich das Ganze um,
damit es einfach schneller abkühlt,
denn es sollte wirklich richtig lauwarm werden.
Ansonsten schmilzt die Sahne auf der Torte.
Um sicherzugehen, dass es fest wird,
gebe ich das jetzt hier noch als Gelierprobe in ein Schälchen
und kann es kurz im Kühlschrank fest werden lassen.
Und hier einfach immer mal wieder umrühren.
[Musik]
Dieses Schmecksperiment - ich sag es euch:
richtig, richtig nicht überlegt!
Ich mache jetzt noch eine Schicht drauf.
Ich hab noch einmal einen Biskuit gebacken. Mir ist die Torte zu flach.
Ich hätte es gern einfach ein bisschen höher.
Diesmal war einfach so unüberlegt so vieles gemacht. Egal.
Es ist okay; darf auch einmal sein.
Können wir das Video "Torten Fail" nennen?
Soll ich Sturmi nominieren?
Ich hätte auch die Torte einfach mit einem Boden höher machen können,
aber dann stimmt ja der Anschnitt nicht.
PATRICK: Daher… wenn schon, dann richtig.
SALLY: Ich brauche noch einmal Creme. Ja.
Ich mache jetzt noch einmal die Creme
und bau das jetzt noch einmal schön. Man wird es nicht merken.
[Musik]
Ich sage es euch: ein Tortendesaster.
Fühlt sich so Sturmi, wenn ich ihn nominiere? [Josh bejaht]
Nur dass er dann zumindest meine Anleitung hat.
JOSH: Hast du ihn gerade gedisst?
SALLY: Ein bisschen, aber er nimmt es mir, glaube ich, nicht übel.
Also auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen größer rundherum,
damit du die Jelly-Masse rein kann.
Das Ganze mit dem Tortenring stabilisieren und vorsichtig,
dass die Folie praktisch nicht an den Früchten klebt.
Ja, mit dem Ring kann man so ein bisschen besser, muss ich sagen.
Okay, hier nach oben, damit nichts ausläuft.
Ihr könnt da sogar noch einen Ring drumherum setzen,
aber ich gucke jetzt einmal.
Also die Masse ist lauwarm.
Da solltet ihr auch aufpassen, dass die praktisch nicht zu fest wird.
Gelierprobe hat super funktioniert.
Da sieht man, dass eben die Masse schön fest ist.
Und jetzt mit einer Suppenkelle am Rand einfüllen.
Und deswegen ist auch wichtig, dass die Torte im Tiefkühlfach war
oder zumindest lange genug in der Kühlung,
damit die Sahne einfach diese leichte Wärme noch aushält.
[Musik] Das Tortendesaster!
Ich hätt's festkleben sollen.
Ah, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich hätte nicht verschieben dürfen. Oh mein Gott!
Oh! Mein! Gott!
Okay. Ariane, kannst du mir vielleicht einen Tortenring geben?
Ja, ja, danke.
Es ist halt so: Wenn mir was einfällt und ich denke.
"Ah, das könnte man und sollte man vielleicht noch machen."
Dann mach's doch einfach. Dann mach's halt
und sag nicht "könnte, wollte, würde".
AUS DEM HINTERGRUND:
No risk, no fun!
SALLY: Ja, das ist echt so. Heute ist so richtig "No risk, no fun!"
Aber so ein Fail macht mir auch kein Fun. Ich sage es euch.
Ich habe schon den Ofen angeschmissen,
weil mir die Torte schon nicht perfekt genug war.
Und ich sag's dir, ich mache noch eine zweite,
einfach ohne dich, Josh. Ohne Kamera. [Josh ist entsetzt]
Es geht gar nicht um dich.
Ich will einfach in Ruhe mit Musik backen und das Ding perfekt machen,
ohne an unsere Schnittbilder denken zu müssen.
Es ist schon, muss man sagen, immer so:
Den Schritt und dann den Schritt zeigen und das moderieren.
Huh, da weiß ich, was mich die letzten Jahre so fertiggemacht hat.
Aber ihr seht, aus Fehlern lernt man.
Das nächste Mal denke ich einfach gleich an mein Bauchgefühl.
Ich schütte es einfach darüber.
Tada!
Also trotz des Verlusts hier - ist gut geworden!
Kann ich das noch?
Oh, aber ich kann es doch kurz erwärmen und da obendrauf noch…
JOSH: Nachdem ich das jetzt gesehen habe, lieber nicht. [Lacht]
SALLY: [Lacht] Ich probiere es.
Weil oben müssen jetzt noch Erdbeeren drauf.
Wisst ihr aber auch? Wir hatten Freitag schon Zeitstress.
und heute haben wir auch Zeitstress.
Der Josh muss nämlich gleich weg.
D.h., ich werde die Torte  gleich kühlen
und kann hier in Ruhe noch fertig werkeln und aufräumen
und wir werden morgen einfach sehen.
Wir dekorieren sie morgen  mit den Eiswürfelchen fertig,
die ich schon vorbereitet habe und dann sehen wir es einfach.
Josh darf zu seiner Impfung gehen, denn die kann er nicht verschieben.
Das müssen wir jetzt heute machen.
Deswegen hatten wir heut echt sehr, sehr Zeitstress.
Aber das ist das Coole bei Agar Agar,
Wenn man das einmal fest hatte,
dann kann man es echt wieder erwärmen.
Das geht bei Gelatine ein bisschen schwieriger.
Und damit kann ich die Erdbeeren noch so fixieren und dann ist es gut.
[Musik]
Ich bin so verrückt.
Ich habe die Torte noch einmal gebacken und extra hoch gefüllt.
Mach es doch gleich so, Sally!
Egal, jetzt haben wir 2 Jelly-Cakes und es ist halt so.
Jetzt ist es halt so.
Jetzt wird sie noch glatt gestrichen.
und ich werde sie dann noch einmal komplett mit Früchten eindecken.
Aber ich mache beide fertig.
Oh, danke.
[Musik]
Geht doch!
Was hat die Praktikantin sich denn gestern so angestellt, diese Sally.
Solche Tage gibt's mal - selten, aber wenn sie kommen, dann richtig!
Also ich hab in den 9 Jahren YouTube-Geschichte…
Da ist mir noch nicht so viel Schlimmes passiert
wie bei dieser einen Torte.
[Musik]
Seit Freitag hatte ich eine Pechsträhne.
Freitag 38 Grad.
Es hat nichts funktioniert. Nun habe ich es gestern neu gemacht.
Gestern ist alles übergelaufen und jetzt habe ich gesagt.
Heute wird der perfekte Tag. Wir retten es heute.
Deswegen habe ich den Allesschneider ausgepackt,
damit die Limetten perfekt sind.
DANI:
Ob es ein Omen ist, dass ich heute da bin?
SALLY: Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen.
Heute ist so ein perfekter Tag und da läuft der Dani durch die Tür.
DANI:
Dann gehe ich jetzt.
SALLY: Ah, guck mal!
Besser kann es heute nicht werden.
DANI:
¡Hasta la vista!
[Musik]
SALLY: Josh, es ist perfekt! [Aww]
JOSH: Die wird echt voll perfekt.
Sag mal, war da gestern nicht Frischhaltefolie drunter?
Muss die drunter? Ja, gell?
SALLY: Ich war abgelenkt.
JOSH: Oops.
SALLY: Ich schaffe das!
Wie kann man 3 Tage lang einen Fehler machen?
JOSH: Tief durchatmen. Alles wird gut. Wir machen sie einfach nochmal.
[Musik]
SALLY: Tolgas Blick war so: Hat sie nicht gemacht!
Das sollte so. [Josh stimmt zu]
Oh, da ist noch ein Blatt.
Sollte ich ein komplett neues Video machen, wie es wirklich geht?
Die macht doch sowieso keiner nach.
JOSH: Das passt schon.
SALLY: Die macht doch eh keiner nach.
Okay. Torte kommt in die Kühlung
und dann mach ich dieses Jelly-Zeug hier auch drauf.
Ich würde sagen, wir packen jetzt mal die andere aus, oder?
Da sehe ich zumindest, ob es geklappt hat.
und ob ich vielleicht bei dieser etwas anders machen müsste.
[Trommelwirbel]
[Grillengeräusche]
Dieses Mal gleich richtig.
[Doing] Ich glaube, ich muss doch erst die Folie.
[Musik]
Ach, so sollte das normalerweise.
Vielleicht kleben wir das heute an.
Oder komm, ich mache wieder einen Ring drum,
einfach, damit die Folie die Jelly-Masse hält.
Kühlen und Jelly-Masse herstellen.
Ich würde jetzt aber 2 l Wasser machen.
Wie kriegt kriegt man unter so einer schweren Torte die Folie weg?
Ach so! [Lacht] Oh Gott!
Ein richtiges Schmecksperiment.
Tolga, kannst du kurz die Platte halten?
[Trommelwirbel] Sonst zieh ich das aus Versehen weg.
Einfach die Glasplatte.
Gut.
Ganz schön schwierige Angelegenheit.
Tadaaa.
Jetzt schauen wir einmal, wie der zweite herauskommt
und dann kommen noch die Eiswürfel und Topping drauf und dann wird probiert.
Es sieht interessant aus.
[Musik]
Okay, die Masse ist lauwarm und ich gieße sie jetzt hier rein
und dann wird es eine perfekte Torte. Ich sag's euch.
[Musik]
[Bedrohliche Musik]
Ich hab doch eine Folie drum!
Darf ich sagen, ich hasse diese Torte, ich hasse sie!
Ah, das ist doch jetzt gar nicht mehr normal!
Die Folie ist doch drunter.
[Singt]
♪ What doesn't kill you makes you stronger. ♪
Ich will ja nichts sagen, aber so eine Torte kann [zensiert]
Ist halt so.
Ich weiß, welche Torte ich nicht mehr brauchen werde.
JOSH: Oh. Oh Gott!
SALLY: Sag nichts! Sag nichts!
Neiiiin!
Ich mach das noch hier.
Es ist so ätzend.
Es hat sich so schön aufgefüllt.
und dann läuft es aber wieder raus.
Die Torte schwebt, die Torte schwimmt. Die schwimmt einfach.
Können wir jetzt bitte, bitte einfach abbrechen
und einfach die Torte essen?
Ich mache dieses Jelly Ding nicht mehr.
Nein, ich mache es nicht.
Können wir das Video einfach nennen:
Oh Gott! Können wir es nennen: Sie hat versagt.
Können wir das bitte drunter schreiben?
Sallys Welt hat versagt!
Die sie doch so viel schöner aus.
Ohne Jelly.
Sahra, die Torte ist fertig. Wir können Fotos machen.
SARAH: [TikTok Song] Oh no, oh no, oh no no no no no.
SALLY: Aber die Farben sehen schön aus.
Kannst du ein Foto machen?
SARAH: Von hier oder von der Torte?
SALLY: Von der Torte natürlich.
SARAH: Mach ich, na klar!
SALLY: Schön, doch echt schön mit dem Glanz.
SARAH: Genau so, wie du es haben wolltest.
SALLY: Ja, ich habe es mit Gelatine probiert,
weil ich wollte, dass es durchsichtiger wird.
Die wird nicht so schnell fest wie Agar Agar.
Ich glaube, hätte ich doch mit Agar Agar gemacht,
wäre es vielleicht nicht so transparent geworden,
aber es wäre schneller fest geworden und nicht ausgelaufen. Egal.
Dieses Video wird veröffentlicht und wir essen jetzt Torte.
Jetzt.
[Musik]
Wenn das Backen schon nicht klappt, macht mich das Putzen glücklich.
Willkommen zum wohl kuriosesten Abschluss eines Sonntagsvideos.
Liebes Sally-Team,
bitte kommt herbei, kommt alle!
Kommt alle, schaut euch alle diesen Fail an!
Seit Freitag.
Was sieht aus?
JUTTA: Sieht doch schön aus.
SALLY: Okay, ich zeige euch kurz ein Foto, wie es hätte aussehen sollen.
[Alle lachen]
JUTTA: Eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit hat es.
SALLY: Ja, also kurz - bei dem war das Problem:
Ich habe es mit Agar Agar gemacht. Es wurde total trüb.
Dann habe ich es mit Gelatine probiert, weil das immer recht klar ist.
Ganz im Ernst: Lasst dieses Jelly Zeug weg.
Ich finde, so ohne Jelly sieht es gut aus. [Das Sally-Team stimmt zu]
SARAH: Sollen wir noch ein Röhrchen reinstecken?
SALLY: Ja, nimm mal! Mach noch ein Röhrchen und ich hol noch die Eiswürfel.
Die hab ich vergessen.
Aber keine Sorge…
JUTTA: Die Eiswürfel sind auch gelb.
SALLY: Keine Sorge. Euer Arbeitsplatz ist nicht gefährdet.
Ich mache sowas einfach nicht mehr.
Wir gehen wieder über zu normalen Rezepten.
Hey Benny, die sind vegan.
BENNY: Ich habe eben grade schon gesagt:
Das sieht aus wie Kuchen in Aspik - wie Sülze.
SALLY: Mit Minze.
BENNY: Die Konsistenz ist nicht so meins,
aber geschmacklich doch besser als gedacht.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Kommt, disst mich ruhig alle! Haut's raus!
Was hast du eben gesagt?
ALINE: Nix.
[Alle lachen]
Ich dachte, es wäre die Tortenrandfolie links
und nicht Gelee.
SALLY: Aber jetzt mit den Eiswürfelchen - komm, geht doch!
Ich finde auch, es glänzt schön.
Leider ist das das einzig Vegane an der Torte und die Erdbeeren.
Aber diese sieht nicht schlecht aus, gell? [Alle außer Max stimmen zu]
Ich glaube, hätte ich sie nicht übergossen, dann wäre sie schön.
Komm, jetzt schneiden wir sie an, jeder probiert eine Gabel.
Soll ich diese anschneiden? Nein, ich schneide diese an.
Ach, es macht auch keinen Unterschied!
JUTTA: Schneide doch beide an!
SALLY: Voll geschmeidig.
SARAH: Was sagst du dazu?
MAX: Ich sage nichts.
SARAH: Du bist noch Azubi, du darfst gar nichts Böses sagen.
MAX: Wunderschön!
SALLY: Ach komm, schon ein perfekter Anschnitt, gell?
Oh, schon schön.
Tadaaa.
ALLE: Awwww
SARAH: Applaus.
[Alle klatschen].
JUTTA: La-Ola-Welle.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Komm, ich gebe jedem eine Gabel. Kommt, gabelt an.
JUTTA: Der Geschmack ist einmalig! Sehr gut!
SALLY: Sieht doch gut aus.
Außerdem machen wir da ein Löffeldessert.
Benny, magst du eine Erdbeere?
MAX: Das kommt auf die inneren Werte an.
SALLY: Also backt die Torte gerne nach, ohne Jelly außen rum.
Ich finde das Muster so oder so echt schön.
SARAH: Ja, sieht aus wie ein Cocktail.
SALLY: Ja, Mojito.
Nächste Woche gibt's wieder was Gescheites. Tschüss!
ALINE: Steckt da ein Strohhalm drin? [Lacht]
SARAH: Weil es ein Mojito ist.
ALINE: Ach so.
SALLY: Und jetzt: Hey Zwerge, hey Zwerge, hey Zwerge ho.
Hey Zwerge, hey Zwerge go go go.
SARAH: Kommt nix.
[Musik]